do you wanna live in a world where
everybody feels cozy validators all the
time what do you want to live in a world
that works we fight new wars the old
options military diplomacy
they don't always succeed sometimes you
need a third option
that's overwatch according to the
government we do not exist for ghosts we
are very real and we get [ __ ] done
we gonna help on this one fun nine
pounds of radioactive isotope is missing
it's enough to make six major cities
uninhabitable he knows exactly where it
is what do you want I want out of the
country this one's it for espionage
we're talking about a corrupt low-level
cop who you're sitting here indicates
he's not so low-level you [ __ ] be
careful
do you have men was wandering our
embassy
and I just put me on a plane to the US
and I'll give you everything to go
there's no water first
the goal is deliver that package to here
mile 22 you know he can't missus guys me
Bob what about to go through
like cuz I can't cheat death
contact venture contact requesting hand
of God got it take
are we Wow our angel can only stay on
the ground two minutes they miss that
window they are there keep coming names
you tell us all that the game today I'll
play everything I've seen maybe
fastball squeeze frame on my history I
think I might be worse I am killer who
looks like a hero
are you feeling calm Alice not even a
little are you I'm totally calm that's
because you're mentally unstable thank
you
you